よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマはびっくりすることかもしれません
善友入門ですから まあちょっとあの
今日はできるだけ早口で喋りますけど
あの 一般的に考えている友人という言葉とは全く違うアプローチなんです
ですので まず覚悟して
友人 友人というご手前になりますね
そこはちょっと置いといて
全く仏教では違うアプローチているんだということで
はい それで善友ということもありながら
このサブタイトルで不放逸という
なんか他の言葉入ってるんですね
まあそれちょっと理解するために
私はすべての生命の良き仲間に
この不放逸ということで
よき良い仲間になるということなんです
では 早速始まります で
これはある経典なんですね
今日は経典 まあほとんど紹介します
このサンユッタニカーヤというテキストに
あの ある経典で あるテキストは五つに分けてあります
かなり大きいんですけど
ボリューム五つですね
それで第一ボリュームでもうコーサラサンユッタというセクションの加せれば 18番目の経典になります
まず出てくる言葉は このあのポイントだけです
スワッカトゥ・バガヴァタ・ダンモ
釈尊に教え 釈尊の教えは正しく説かれている
なんか大したことない単語やと思いますけど
正しく喋ってるんだと
見事に喋ってるんだということでもあります
この正しく語っているスワッカタというのは
パーリ語ではかなり深い意味なんですね
いわゆる見事に 完璧に
完全に 何の欠陥もなく
何の疑いも出てこないようにピシッと語っているんだよと
誤解とか生まれません
曖昧は全くない ピシッと
大体法律用語はできるだけピシッと書こうとするんですよ
法律項目は それでも結構曖昧が出てくるんです
なかなか大変です で これ
法律のこと 法律言語よりもしっかり語っているんだということなんです
で ソーチコ・カルヤーナ・ミッタッサ・カルヤーナ・サハーヤッサ・カルヤーナ・サンパワン・カッサ
しかし それが合うのは誰かというと
善友に善友の仲間に 善に赴く人に適しています
教えは完璧ですけど これは合わない人々もいますと
ブッダの教えは気に入らない人々もいます
まあインターネット 私にも結構くたくた言われていますけどもね
まあそういうもう普通の文化からはみ出された方々も結構います
常識はないとかね で まあこの場合は常識はないということでよくてよりも
このこれはやっぱり合わない
理解できない人々もいるんだということです
それで理解できる人は誰かというと
善友なんですね この言葉がね
この日本訳はそうやって
まあ私の訳ですから 間違いはあると思いますけど
私はまあ大体訳するんです
ぴったし訳しようとはしないんです
で 私はこの一般的に訳されている意味よりも別な意味が読まれてしまうんですよ
この行間というかね これ言っていいかどうかよくわからなくなったって
で カルヤーナっていうのは良いということで
ミッタっていうのは友人フレンドなんですね
このミッタはフレンドリネスという風にも訳できます
で カルヤーナっていうのは良いことにとてもフレンドリー
フレンドリーっていうか
フレンドリー とても良いことにフレンドリー
これは 言語学ではまあ戦友なんですけど
パーリ言語を調べたら戦友
しかし私に 私に個人的には
フレンドリーネスとグッドというふうに読めるんですね
良いことに対して 自分の心にあるフレンドリーネスというフレンドを知ってますね
このフレンドにフレンドリーネスといえば
フレンドシップ フレンドリーネスという言葉はあまり使いませんだけど
フレンドシップなんですね
フレンドシップウィズグッドネス
というとすごく意味が違いますよ
いい友達よっていうことと
善に対する友好感なんです
番目の言葉は カリャーナサハヤス
サハヤっていうのは まあ誰と仲良くしているのかっていう
それも仲間と訳するんですよ
しかし サハヤといえば
あなた誰と仲良く関わりを持っていますか？というと
カリャーナ良いことと
善悪で考えてください
悪に反対して 私は善と仲良くしているんだよと
それから次 カリャーナサンパワンカッサ
これは善に赴く どうしても善の方に惹かれてしまいます
という意味は読めます
しかし 表面的には良い友達がいて
良い友達の仲間がいて
まあ人にしか仏道はブッダの教えは気に入らないんだと他の人々にという意味になります
ノーパパミッタッサノーパパサハヤッサノーパパサンパワン
それは反対ですね 悪友に悪友の仲間に
悪に赴く人には適していない
だからそこは逆に今私は自分好き勝手にした訳から見れば
悪とフレンドリーネスがあればね
フレンドシップは悪 で
誰と仲良くするのかというと
悪と一緒 仲良くする で
心がどこに赴いているかというと
悪の方向に赴いている
だったらこの人にはダメということになります
こうそう こうされた国王
こうした国王が以上のことを釈尊に報告するんです
これは国王の言葉なんですね
お釈迦様ってものすごい見事に教えてますよと
しかし あれはね いい仲間にいる人にしか合わないんだと
悪人と仲良くしている人にはもう決して合わないということを言ったんですね
良い仲間がいる人だったら
ブッダの教えはぴったし気に入りますと
で 認めますね それからアーナンダ尊者の発言もあります
釈尊がその発言をそのまま認める
さらに戦友について 語られる
はい これからエピソード
釈尊が国王にその通りですと
あなた言う通りですと言ってから
あるエピソードを言うんですね
お釈迦様が自分の親族のサカ族の国にいた時
ナガラカという町があったんですね
そこでアーナンダ尊者がこういうことを言うんですね
戦友がいることで修行の半分成功に達しますと言ったのです
それでコウスロ王に言うんで
あんた知ってますかね
私はナガラカにいた時
アーナンダ尊者 アーナンダ君が出てきて
お釈迦様 戦友と出会うことをできれば
修行は半分成功しますよと
修行の道の半分進みますよということを言ったんですね
ウパッダミダ ウパッダミダン バンテーブラフマチャリアッサ ヤディダン カリャーナ ミッタタ カリャーナ サハヤタ カリャーナ サンパワンカタという
あの これ専門用語になってます
カリャーナ ミッタタ カリャーナ サハヤタ カリャーナ サンパワンカタですから
ずっと繰り返しこれ出てくるんです
私は前 私の個人的な訳もありましてね
善に善と善と仲良くする
でということと 善に赴く性格
それだったら一人のことなんですね
個人の問題なんですね
友達として取っちゃうと
良い友達と仲良くすること
両方を取った方がいいと思います
意味 2つだと 仏道を実行できる
実践できるのは誰かというと
良い友達がいる人と 自分が善に親しみを感じる人である
この 2つ 個人の性格と友達がいること
そこでアーナンダ尊者が言うのは
修行は半分成功できますよと
お釈迦様はアーナンダ尊者の言葉を却下するんですね
釈尊がその言葉を却下する
戦友に出会うことで修行が完成
完成するのです いわゆる修行のすべてというんですね
このパーリ語でサカラ メーワ ヒダン アーナンダ ブラフマチャリアン
ブラフマチャリアンというのは
仏教の修行そのもの すべてまとめて釈尊が教える教え
すべて実践するセクションはブラフマチャリアと言うんです
学ぶところはダンマ法というんですね
仏教はただ学生さんみたいに頭だけで学ぶ場合は
それは法を学んでいて
やってみる場合はブラフマチャリアと言うんですね
仏教って科学ですから
理論があって 実践がある
両方で成り立っています
科学も論理だけでは何にも役に立たんでしょう
理論だけでは 科学のありがたみは
何でもやってみる 実験してみる
それですごい世界が現れたでしょ
だから科学はなんですごいかというと
ちゃんと実験するんだからなんです
頭でっかちで言うのはいたって簡単でしょ
あの宇宙にも生命がいるんだぞとかね
まあ推測的に言えばいるに決まってますけどね
膨大な宇宙だから でもそれは理論だけで
未だに科学者の手には証拠が入ってないんですね
だから頭でっかちだけで言うならばいくらでも言えますよ
しかし 科学のすごいところは実践するところなんで
移行してみる 使ってみる
仏教も初めからもう まあその 2つにいつでも分け
ダンマ ヴィネヤと 昔使った言葉はダンマ
ヴィネーア ダンマは教え
ヴィネーアはもうディシプリン
自分がその通りにやること
それからブラフマチャリアという言葉も使いました
ブラフマチャリアにも言葉意味 2つがありまして
この結婚しないで性行為を止めることをブラフマブラフマチャリアとインドで言ってますけど
お釈迦様がその意味ではなくて
ものすごい尊い 究極に尊い道というふうな意味で取られているんですね
ブラフマというのは インド人が信仰した絶対的な神の言葉なんです
神なんですね これ 絶対的神の生き方をするんだよと
ということは 一番最高な生き方やってみる
仏教は絶対的神は認めません
お釈迦様はこんなのありえないんだと言うんだけど
言葉として 文化として
人間の気持ちとして 神という概念があるんですね
人間の気持ちとして 頭の中にある神の観念が一番最高なものなんですね
まるっきり誰にも敵わないものなんです
その人間の気持ちを使って語っているんです
ですから ブラフマチャリアっていうのは一番究極的に優れた生き方
そこでお釈迦様がサカラメーワヒダンブラフマチャリア
この生き方 すべて一つのクラス
完璧に カルヤーナミッタタ
カルヤーナサハーヤタ
カルヤーナサンパワンカタという 3つに入れちゃうんです
じゃあ我々一般的に知っている善友がいることで修行は完璧に完成します
だから もっとわかりやすく言えば
仏教瞑想でもして悟りに達したいと思ったら
たった一つの条件 善友がいるのかいと
善友がいるならばもう文句なし
悟りに達しますと 必要なただそれだけやと
いう意味で世界はこの経典は読んでいるんです
で 私はそれだったらね
善友に出会うチャンスない人々はね
残念ですねと あんた方は残念ですと
失格やと言っていいのかと
だからもう一つ意味があるはずなんですね
その私が言っている 2番目に意味っていうのは
フレンドシップウィズグッドネスなんですね
自分が善ということと仲良くしているのかいと
善と付き合っている性格なのかと
心がたとえ悪いことしちゃっても
やっぱり趣が良い方に向いているんだと
時々いますよ まあ漁師とかね
悪行為しなくちゃいけない仕事をしている人々も
で 家の仕事をだからやってはいるんだけど
あんまり気持ちとしては
まあこんなことやらない方がいいんじゃないかな
別の仕事あればいいんじゃないかなとかね
だからたとえ漁師であっても
時々心が善の方に赴く場合ありますよ
お釈迦様はそういう人々は救うんです
行って助けてあげるんです
だから必ずしも ということではなくて
悪行為をしていても やむを得ず
例えば法律的に人をなんて言いますか
処刑というんですか もうやるばやるでしょう
誰かがやらなくちゃあかんでしょ
それが それって人殺しでしょ
人殺すんですよ 法律 合法的やと言ったっても
ね だからその注射を入れる人とかね
何人かがやっぱり人殺しに参加しているんですよ
いや その人々はすごく喜んで
いい仕事だと これはとかね
給料も普通より高くて
毎日やらなくてもよろしいし
結構休みが多いだろうとかね
えらい調子に乗っちゃうと人殺しを喜んでいるんですね
悪に赴いているんですね
ではなくて まあしょうがない仕事だから
まあもう本当はなんで人間いいことをしないのか
なんで人殺すんでしょうかね
まあこちらまで嫌な思いでにならなくちゃあかんやとかね
いう気分でやる場合は
やっぱり心が自分 本当は手を加えて人を殺しているんだけど
気持ちはそんなことはやりたくないと
その場合は この 3番目の専門用語
何といいますか カリアのサンパワン方
善に赴く だからそういう性格があったら OK ですよ
はい それでお釈迦様はさらに戦友の話説明します
戦友に出会うことで 聖なる八正道を実践するんだよと
この八正道を持ってくるんで
お釈迦様が 皆様はびっくりするでしょ？戦友って誰ですか？と教えるべきところで
なんで八正道が参り込んでくるんですかね
お釈迦様勘違いでもしてるんですかね
そこで善友といったら
仏教は我々では全然思いつかない別なことを言っているんです
ただ友達がいるって意味じゃないんです
この八正道の 8項目 だいたいご存知の方々はたくさんいると思いますけど
正見 正思惟 正語とかね
正命 正業 正精進 正定 正念とか
まあいろいろある  8 ありますよ
サッマディティ サッマサンカッパ
サッマワーチャ サッマカンマンタ
サッマアジーワ サッマワーヤム
サッマティ サッマサマーディ
パーリ語で言えば 日本語では覚えてないんです
私は そちらに正サンマということがあるんですよ
サンマ正っていうのは正しいっていう意味でしょ
間違ったことはしないっていうことなんです
だから八正道って面白くて
誰にでもわかりやすいんですよ
間違ったこと考えたくないでしょうに
間違った見解は持ちたくないでしょうに
気持ちどうしても気持ちだけで
本当は間違った見解ばっかしで
気持ちは間違った考えはしたくないんですけど
やっているのはほとんど間違っている考えばっかしで
正しい言葉を語りたいと思ってはいるんだけど
喋ってみたらとんでもないこと
とんでもないことを言っちゃったとかね
いうことですね 世界は
そこでお釈迦様善友といえば
これはもう正しい道を歩むことであると
八正道を歩むことであるというんです
そこでまた問題が出てくるんです
八正道といえば どんな仏教本を読んでみたっても
すごい一般的な説明ばっかしなんですね
ただ 私たちの理解範囲の八正道ではないんです
正語っていうのはもう正しく語ることでしょうと
そんな甘くはないんです
経典でも嘘をつかないこと
無駄話しないこと 二枚舌でないことですよ
それから粗悪語 厳しい失礼な言葉を使わないという
それが正語です よくわかりますね
誰でもわかる教えですね
ブッダの教えはと思っちゃいます
しかし そんな甘い話じゃないんです
ものすごいとてつもない意味があるんです
それは全然仏教の本を読んでもね
ないんです どんなもう
私は英語の本しか参考にしないんですけど
あの どんな本を読んでみたっても
まあ普通に誰にでも理解できる 4つの説明するんです
経典にもそういう説明あります
しかし 発見できる人は発見するんだそうと言って思って
お釈迦様がちゃんと自分が思った意味を説かれています
これは発見できる人 その能力ある人は発見します
俗世間を乗り越える目的があるんです
我々人間としての認識範囲を破って
生命としての次元を破って解脱に行くというすごい目的があるんです
そういうことで 八正道はこの特色がなければダメなんです
ヴィヴェーカニッシタン
様々な対象から離れる
これ無理です あのヴィヴェーカっていうのは
我々は この世界と厳しいコネクションでいるんですよ
目から繋げているでしょ？耳から世界と繋げているでしょ
肉体から世界に繋げているでしょ
鼻から味から世界と繋がっているんですね
それからいろんなことを考えたりすることでも世界と繋がっている
これから喋ることで 私は世界に向けて発信しているんですよ
それは繋げなんですね
そこでいろんなことをやっているでしょうに
皆様は仕事をするということは
世界との繋げでしょ 仕事をして世界にあげる
その代わりにいくらかお金をいただく
だからそうやってあらゆるコネクションがあって我々生きているんです
動物も生命はみんなそうなんですよ
世界とずっと繋がりがなければ生きていられませんよ
じゃあミミズはどうですか？皆様に 1度たりともこんにちはと言ったことはある？ないでしょ
じゃあ世界と何でも関係なく生きていると思っている
そうじゃないんです ビシッとこの世界と関係を持って生きているんです
微生物は 目に見えないんだから
誰とも関係ないとかありませんよ
ちゃんと世界と関係を持って生きているんです
だから 生きるためには
世界とこの精密なという
何と言いますかね ものすごい硬い絆で繋げてないと生きていられないんです
これは切れない絆なんです
この絆を切るために八正道やりなさいと言っているんです
できる 見るものに依存しない
聞くものに依存しない
勝手に聞けるのは構わないんだけど
聞きませんと 勝手に見えるのは構わないんだけど
見ませんと 勝手に鼻に香りが入り込むのは勝手にしろよと
私は嗅ぎませんと 勝手に味が感じるのは勝手にしろよと
私は味わいませんと で
体がある場合は空気が触れたり
椅子は椅子が触れたりするでしょうに
しかし私は振らせませんと
自分はもう関係切る 一番の
難しいのは思考 思考はしません
思考することで妄想することで
我々はずっと世界と関わり持っているんです
そういうことで このまるっきりわからない
難しいでしょう この絆を足す目的で
あの結構難しいんですけど
じわじわと立っていけます
立ったところで解脱です
仏道はそういう生きることを応援するのではなくて
このだらしないこの生き方を切る
やめるという逆方向を行く道を説かれているんです
だから これは一般人には全く理解できないだからあまり言わないんです
で またほぼ同義語ですけど
ヴィラーガニッスタン
欲 執着をなくす おなじみなんですね
離れ離れても執着があると
だから苦しいんですよ
子供は一人暮らししたいと言ったら
まあいいですよと 言ってお母さんが一生懸命ね
もうお金もあげて 住むところも探して
もう掃除もしてあげて
もうすごいバンバンされて一人暮らしさせますけど
子供に対して愛着があるとやっぱり苦しいんですよ
一応離れました 一応やりましたが
心になんか残っちゃいますね
寂しさが で  2番目はそれ
心からの執着を捨てる
3番目ニロードニッスタン
まあこれは煩悩を滅する
そこで執着やら怒りやら欲やら
いろんなものが心にあるんだから
それでコネクションを取ってるんです
生きていきたいということが一番大きい煩悩なんですよ
生きていきたい 誰も知らない
何のためにあんた生きてるのかいと調べたらないでしょう
何もないんです で 面白いことは
まあ私は生きていくで
なんでやというと 家族がいるんだとかね
仕事があるんだとか あなたが亡くなるとみんな死にますかと
全然痛くも痒くもないでしょ
人が死んじゃっても社会には
だから自分の存在価値って何ですかね
社会は生きてくださいと頼んでないんです
で 死んじゃっても別にまるっきり知らないんですね
何の影響もないんです
この偉大なる人物という人々も
死んだんだからといって何のこともないんです
世界はそのまま ということは
この世界で生きている我々の役割って何ですかね
なんかお呼びでない存在でしょ
で お呼びでない存在にも気づかなくて
とにかく生きていきたいと思っているんですね
だから無理に強引にコネクションを作るんですよ
だからお釈迦様はそんなことをやる前に
この執着を捨てたらどうですかと
煩悩をなくしたら楽じゃない？いきなり自由になりますよと
いうこと これ解脱を涅槃を教えているんですね
それは 3番目 この 3つが必要なんですね
八正道に それで八正道っていうのは
ちょっと頭がいい人に自分でも考えられますよ
八は出てこないと思いますけど
正しい言葉を喋りましょう
正しいことを考えましょうという連中はいくらでもいますね
八もミスからないんだけどね
時々ありますね 現代社会になってくると集中力が必要でしょうとかね
集中力っていうのは症状 7番目でしょ
8番目 八正道の でも なんで集中力が必要かといったら
だって集中すると勉強できるでしょう
仕事できるでしょう その程度のその程度の話なんです
集中力あったら結構気持ちいいでしょう
そんな程度 だから八正道の項目は
八も一人の人間には発見できんだけど
まあいくつか 一つ 二つ
三つ 四つとか語る人はいるんです
お釈迦様は八項目にしたんですが
これが誰にも言えないところなんです
この三つの特色は もう一つあった
4番目 ウォッサッガパーリミー
だいたいこの 4つは一応同義語だと思っても構わない
ウォッサッガっていうのは汽車を目指す
捨てることを目指すんです
取る取る取るではなくて
捨てる 捨てる 捨てる さようなら
さようなら さようならと
いかにさようならと言えるのかという能力を上げるんです
欲しい欲しいっていうのは
犬猫にもできますよ さようならと言うためには
相当精神的な力が必要なんです
はい さようなら 要りませんと言うためには
そこは究極的に この喜捨ということを実践してみるんです
そのために八正道です
いわゆるまとめて言うと
解脱に解脱へ導く八正道です
八正道はお釈迦様が一般論で
も語るが 本当の意味はそうじゃないんです
一般論じゃなくて 人間に理解が難しい解脱論なんです
はい それでお釈迦様がおっしゃるのは
ということで 善友とは私ですよと
世の中で善友一人しかいないんです
ママンヒアーナンダカルヤナミッターンアーガッマ
で あ もうちょっと私は抜けたところがありまして
お釈迦様は先にこの善友の指導で
人々が四つの特色ある八正道を実践しますよと
悟りに達しますよと ということで
なんか変な定義ですよ
善友とは悟りへ導く人のことなんです
善友とは 我々の生命次元を破るために助ける人なんです
例えば 生命がドカンとすごい大きな穴に落ちているんですね
もう上がらないんで滑るんです
壁は で 我々は生命はでっかい輪廻という穴に落ちているんです
もう抜けられないんです
そこで誰かが来て ロープを出して
はい これ捕まってくださいと
と引いてあげるんです
それが善友です 今落ちている泥沼から立ち上がるために手を差し伸べる
そういうことで 輪廻という泥沼に泥沼に落ちている我々に
輪廻から脱出するためのアドバイスをする人が善友ですね
世の中にいる人々のことじゃないんです
ということで お釈迦様が善友になるんです
他の人々ではないんです
なのでお釈迦様はこう解くんですね
善友たる私に出会うことで
正気性質の生命は 生起から解放される
生起っていうのは生まれてるは生まれる
起こるなんですね ずっといろんなこと生まれるんですよ
生まれっぱなしなんで
人生っていうのはいろんなこと
これってめんどくさいんですよ
苦しいんですよ 例えば地震が生起するでしょ？楽しい？じゃないでしょうに
で 家が崩壊するでしょ
それも生起なんですね
崩壊が生起しちまったと
もう落ち着かないでしょ
私たちは無意識的にいつでも現状維持したいという気持ちがあるんですよ
現状維持 それで安心するんです
仕事は安定しているならばね
まあ気持ちいいんですよ
家族は何のことなく そのままずっと動いてくれればもう OK ですよ
だから現状維持っていうことは常に期待するんです
電車に乗るときは 皆様は全然心配しないでしょ
まあしっかりと目的地まで行くと思ってるんですね
そんなの本当はありえませんだけどね
突然人身事故になったり
地震が起きたり あれ 上あるなんとか電線
高架線 なんとかそれ壊れたり
パンタグラフが引っかかったりする可能性もあるでしょうに
その時はえらい不安になってしまいますね
だから我々の無意識な心はいつでも現状維持
現状維持ということでやっていたんですが
やっているんですが 物事は止まらないんですよ
いつでも新しいものが生まれてくるんですね
これでもう嫌で嫌で苦しんでるんです
これはずっと生まれるということがあるんですよ 1
秒たりとも生まれないという瞬間がないんです
何か新たなものが生まれる
これに調整しなくちゃあかんです
また新たなものが生まれる
また調整しなくちゃあかん
やりきれないんです それって苦しみなんです
で 生起の性質の生命は生起から解放されますよと
ジャラダンマサッタジャラパリムッチャンティ
老いる性質の生命は老いから解放されますよ
ビャーディダンマサッタビャーディトパリムッチャンティ
病に陥る生命は病から解放されますよ
マラナダンマサッタマラネーナパリムッチャンティ
死性質の生命は死から解放されますと
ということで あらゆるこの苦しみの元
これなんですよ この生老病死なんですよ
これが苦しみの大本 どうにもならん
その上にまたさらに苦しむんです
生老病死という 4本柱の苦しみがありまして
その上で建物を作っているんです
その建物も苦しみなんです
お釈迦様が私の家の友達に出会うと解放されますよと
ということは 泥沼に落ち落ちている人を助けてあげますよということなんです
ソーカパリデーヴァドッカドーマナッサーウパヤーサダンマサッタ
また長い文章ですから省略しました
ソーカパリデーヴァドッカドーマナッサーウパヤーサウパヤーサンハパリムッチャンティなんです
憂い 悲しみ 苦しみ 悩み
落ち込んでいる生命は
落ち込みから解放されるんです
仏教に出会うと憂い悲しみから解放されます
戦友とはただの友達ではありませんね
結論が 戦友ってただ友達でしょう？ではないんです
はい それで一段落 仏教の本当のことを教えたんです
だからお釈迦様はもうあまりこれ言いたくないと
人間にわからないんだと
だってこのコネクション
一切切るということは頭に入らないでしょう
どうやって理解すればいいんですかね
理解する過程も教えています
離れる方が楽やと アチャンチャーさんのタイのね
ある有名なお坊様がいてね
で ちょっとしたエピソードがありまして
この村 すごい田舎で生活していたんだからね
ものすごい風があって
雨が降って もう木が倒れちゃって
道場に行く道ももう木が倒れて閉ざしちゃった状態になっちゃって
で みんなこの外国の坊主たちも
タイ人もきれいにしているんですね
アチャンチャーは一番偉いお坊様でしたけど
年でしたし それで 一緒に綺麗にしているんです
木があって 横に倒れた木があって
若いお坊さん誰か呼んでね
これ運びましょうと言って
みんなでよっこらしょとこれ運んで
道路から持っていって
ではここら辺に捨てましょうよとアチャンチャー言うんですね
で みんなドカンと道路に捨てたんですね
あの木を そしたらアチャンチャーが一言葉
捨てたら楽ですね それだけ
捨てたら楽ですねと で
そうやって説法する それだけな説法は
だからすごい偉大なるお坊様として
もう世界的に尊敬されているんです
私みたいにうるさくてね
何言ってるかわからなくて
延々と喋ることはないんです
はい でも捨てる 捨てたら楽ということは
あんな経験みたいなところから理解できますよ
だから捨てれば楽 一切捨てれば
捨てることできれば究極的な楽なんです
その安楽は消えませんね
だって捨ててから楽だから
だから金が例えば 10 万があって楽しみが生まれたならば
金が減ると楽しみも減りますよ
金がゼロ ない すごい楽やと思ったら
その人の楽は消えませんでしょ
ということで 捨てる楽は残るんです
得る楽はもう束の間 で
2番目のセクションに入ります
難しい話をしてから相手が国王でしょう
もうだらしない もう欲に溺れてる人間だからね
コーサラ国王が で 悟りに達してないんです
お釈迦様と随分会話対話しているくせに
なんで経典のワンセクションもコーサラ王に入れてあるかというと
もうインドで言ったら一番大きい国なんですね
インドの当時の 16 ぐらい国がありましたけど
まあ他の国を占領して占領して取っちゃって
この人の国が一番大きいんです
お釈迦様の国も取られちゃったんです
だからまあ政治的に権力的にインドで言ったら一番トップの人だから
まあ彼がお釈迦様に会いたいと言うなら断りますと
できませんでしょ？で
彼がもう好き勝手なお釈迦様に会って話したりする
まあその時は決して無駄な話はしていないんですけどね
そこまでお釈迦様に仲良くしたのに
悟ったかというと 悟ってはないんです
それからコーサラ国王にアドバイスするんです
カルヤナミットーバビッシャーミ
カルヤナサンサハヨ カルヤナサンパワンコーティ
善友になります 善友の仲間になります
善に赴きますと努力しなさいと
これで私の前の解説は合っているとわかりますね
俺は善友になりますと言ったっても意味がないでしょう
一人勝手で やっぱりそれは個人の性格なんですよ
善友ではなくて なくなく
フレンシップウィズグッドなんです
だから心の中で善と友達になることなんです
だから人が決めなくちゃいけないんですよ
皆様も 私は今日から善友になりますと決めなくちゃいけないんです
誰の友達ではないんです
そこ誰もいないんです
私が善友になります なんです
これで仏教が教えようとしている
この難しいところを理解できると思います
私が善と関わりを持ちます
私が善に赴く生活をしますということで
これ個人の責任なんです
善友になることは 善友になるんであって
善友を釣ってみようかなと言って
釣り竿を持って歩くんじゃないんです
人の肩を立ててね あなた
私の善友になってくれませんか？とかね
その話じゃないんです
はい それがアドバイス
1でアドバイス 2が入ります
アヤンエーコーダンモウパニッサイビハタブー
それでコーサラ王様がもう途方に暮れちゃうでしょう
善友になりますと言っても
あれってなんですかねとかね
だから自分だけの修行でしょ
あれってなんですかね
善友になると言ったって
もうどうすればいいんですかね
善と仲良くなると言ったっても
善と言ったってばいっぱいあるでしょ
笑うこともいいことで
人を助けることもいいことで
国を治めることも良いことでしょうしね
キリがないでしょ あってもおかしくなっちゃいますね
皆様も同じ問題あると思います
皆様は良い人間になりたいと思っているんだけど
どうすればいいかわからないでしょ
同じ質問を私にある女の子が聞いたこともありますよ
おばあさんがいつでも良い人間になりなさいと言ってますよと
しかしよくわかりませんと
良い人間になるということはどういうことですかと私に聞いたんです
だからおばあちゃんも孫のことを心配してて
良い人間になりなさいと言うんだけど
言ってるおばあちゃんも知らないんですよ
良い人間とは何なのかと
それ知らないで言ったって意味がないでしょ
だから子供が正直に私に聞いたんで
私はまあ答えたんですけど
そこで同じ問題 この経典にありますね
コーサラ王様にお釈迦様はアドバイスします
決めなさい 善友になりますと
善と友に友達になりますと決めなさいと
善と だから善友なんです
善と友達になることが善友なんです
問題は善って何ですかっていうことなんです
それでブッダこそが究極な友達なんですよ
一言葉で教えるんです
一言葉で 先方というのは
行為に対しては怠らないという
たった一個の項目を身に付いて生活するべきですと
怠らないという不放逸ですね
それを守ってよと 良いことは何でしょうかと決めるんじゃなくて
その人とその人と良いことに出会うでしょう
良いことに出会うたびに
それに怠らない さっとやる
私たちの日常 24時間の人生の中でいろいろでしょうね
その中でたまたま良いことにも出会いますよ
その時恥ずかしがらないで
まあなんかやる気がなかったとか
それがなくて さっと怠らないでやる
善行に出会った瞬間でやっちゃいましょうよと
放逸になってはならん
そう言われたって 私は疲れたとか
例えば年寄りの方に座席を譲ると
まあまだ若者何人かいるんだから誰かやるでしょう
言ったら怠ったんですね
見た瞬間で じゃあやりますということで
自分やる それはパーリ語であっというんですね
だから楽でしょ お釈迦様の教えは難しいんだけど
実践 実行しようとすると随分わかりやすく教えるんです
ただ不放逸でいるだけ
あのチャンスは逃さない
それだけ 人を助けるチャンスがあったらサッとやる
良いことをするチャンスがあったらすぐやる
じゃあそれだけ はい これだけで終わり
専有になる方法 不放逸でいれば専有です
なんかすごい難しいところから
ものすごい簡単なところに来たんです
実践できるところに だから私が専修になりますということだけお釈迦様おっしゃっているんです
いい友達がないんだから
私はだらしないんだよと言ったら
それはとんでもない話ですよ
人にせいにするんじゃないよと
先生が悪かったんだから勉強できなかったとか
親が厳しかったんだから私はダメな人間になったとか
よく言うでしょう これはとんでもない
仏教ではもうとんでもない話です
だから良い友達に出会わなかったんだから
私は悟ってないんだよと
そんなこと言ってる場合じゃないんです
私が専有になりますなんです
では 何すればいいかというと
善を行うチャンス 機会は絶対見逃せませんという不放逸
アッパナーダ それだけ守る
王が不放逸に生活するならば
家族 宮殿の人々も不放逸になる
王族皆不放逸になろうとする
王が不放逸に生活するならば
軍隊も不放逸になろうとする
国民も不放逸になろうとする
王が不放逸に生活するならば
自分を守ることになる
ただ自分を守る 王様っていうのはいつでも怯えているでしょう
軍隊に警備にしてもらったりして守られませんよ
暗殺されますからね こうすれば王様も殺されましたよ
最後に殺されてはなかったんですけど
最後のエピソードは悲しいんです
歳になってボロボロになったところで
またコソコソとお釈迦様にあったんです
で 長い時間隠れて喋っていたんです
で それであのコーサラ王様がだいたいお釈迦様に会って
よく長い時間喋ると こいつはとんでもない王で
外へ出てどこかの国を攻めたりするんです
あれは一つ この隠すためにも使うんですよ
自分のからくりを そこで年も取ってからまた長い時間喋ってるんだから
次何やるかわからないってことで
この人がお釈迦様に会う
この場合はこの個人で会いたかったんですね
人間として だから国王のすべてのお印のもの
刀やら魔法 指にはめる輪っかがありますね
指輪 それとベルトと これを頭にかぶるものとか
いくつかあります を象徴するもの
これを全部ある大臣に渡したんです
渡して あんた外で待ちなさいと
そう お釈迦様と会いますと
で 国王を通せではなく
一人の人間としてあって
まあ年寄りだから普通の話をしたんですよ
話は今日手に残ってますけどね
まあそう言ったのは お釈迦様
実は私はこの国の国王ですよと
国王たる私がお釈迦様の足に額をつけて礼をしますと
3回やったんです だから自分が国王であると言わなくちゃいけない
今何もないんだから バッジは
ただお釈迦様 あのね あなた
この肉体に何でそんなにも尊敬するんですかと
この肉体にとお釈迦様客観的に見るんだからね
言ったらお坊様がなんでお釈迦様を信頼するのかっていうことを延々と言うんですね
その中で歴史的なことっていうのは
まあお釈迦さんはコーズラ国の人であるし
私もコーズラ国の人です
お釈迦様も 80歳で 私も 80歳ですよとか
そういうくだらないことなんです
言って外へ出てくると
あの大臣がいないんです
誰もいないんです 王様を連れていく人々は
大変なことになっちゃったと
のこのこと自分で歩いていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
宮殿まで あの大臣とのグループの人々はさっさと宮殿に戻って
息子にあって もう今日からあなたは王であると言って
もうなんて革命を起こすっていうか
クーデターなんですね
追い出されちゃったんで
チャンスを見つけて そこで門のところに誰も入るなよと
変な人が来るかもしれませんよと
それで言って このおじいさんが門が開けろ
あんた誰ですかと 知らんかと
俺はここコーズラ国王でしょうにと
誰もあのおじさんの人間見てないんだからね
結局はそれはつらいところですよ
派手な王は見たことあるんですけど
人間たるおじさんが見たことないんですね
なんだ こんな変なじじい
頭おかしいでしょ 出ていけって追い出されたんです
そこで外でホームレスになっちゃって
その夜死んじゃったんです
だから悲しいんですよ
最後は  そういうことで
軍隊がいても自分を守ってくれませんよ
しかし 不放逸でいれば
それこそ自分の守りなんですね
心ですからね 肉体じゃないんだから
心は善行為のチャンス
逃さない生き方だったら
いつだって善行為するチャンスなんです
例えば 死にかけていると
それ苦しいでしょ 全部恋するチャンスなんですよ
寝たきりになったら善行為するチャンスなんですよ
体ってこんなものやとかね
欲張ったっても なんでバカバカらしいかと
そういうふうに瞑想するチャンスなんです
もう後戻りはないだろうと
今まで一生懸命やったものは
すべてもう私に関係なくなったでしょうにと
自分の子供たち 孫たちに至っても
もう関係なくなったでしょうにと
ああ かわいいと思っただけで苦しくなるでしょうにと
孫と遊びたいなと 寝たきりの人は思っちゃうと苦しいんですよ
遊べないんだからね その瞬間ね
やっぱり執着を捨てた方が楽ですね
体に対して執着させた方が精神的に楽
体中痛いし 足が動かない
手が動かない 喉が動かない
だから点滴で栄養をとっている
酸素を入れている ご飯食べたいとかね
まあみかん食べたいとか思っちゃうと苦しいんですよ
だからじゃあ体に執着させた方が結構楽ですねとかね
いうふうなことで 寝たきりになっても善行為するチャンスがあるんです
24時間あります 最初はたまたま見つかりますけど
どんどん成長すると いつだって善行為するチャンスでしょと見えてくるんです
それは不放逸の素晴らしいところなんです
そういうことで 自分を守るためにたった一つしかない
不放逸 アッパマーダ これはパーリ語でも覚えた方がいいんです
自分を守ることになる
お妃たちも守ることになる
財産も守ることになるとなると
財産まで言っちゃうんですね
財家の人に喋りますからね
その意味をね 今 財家に対して教えるんですからね
意味をこの詩で 歌で ガーターで
偈頌と言うんですね まとめているんです
富を期待するならば ボーゲーパッテーマーネーナウラーレアパラアパレ
アッパマダンパサンサンティプンヤキリアーすパンディタ
この世であの世で これどう読みますかね
たくさん富をね 願うものには
賢者は善行に対して不放逸であることが良いと称えるんです
意味がわかりやすいんですよ
これ スリランカの坊さんたち
よく説法するとき使う
それで私はそういう偈は使わないんですよ
で この世で豊かになりたければ
死後もいっぱい豊かで生活したければ
不放逸を実践しなさいと賢者が言うんだよと
賢者ってのはブッダのことなんです
ですから 中国人がよくやっていますね
葬式では向こうでも金持ちになるようにと思って
いっぱい金を印刷 金のようなものを印刷して
こう束束燃やすんです
あるいはこの世でも金じゃないんですけど
あの世で飛行機に乗れるようにと言って
でっかいジャンボ機とか紙で作って燃やすんです
だからあの世でも幸せになりたいんですよ
あれは中国の葬式のしきたりなんですよ
ある人がこの金持ちの人が死んじゃったんで
その葬式のためにでっかい宮殿のような建物を作ってるんです
紙で 段ボール 紙とかね
普通の紙で綺麗に作って
メイドさんまで庭師 メイドさん
それからすごいロールスロイスとかね
すごい高い車とか これ紙で作って入れたりして
で それはもう法事をやって燃やすんです
そうすると あの世で全部もらえますよと
よく信じてやっていることで
だからこれ人間のアホな期待ですけど
お釈迦様が言うのは こんなアホらしいことではなくて
不放逸でいなさいよと
不放逸でいたらこの世でも豊かになりますよと
だから王様も国の財産に対してすごい管理しなくちゃいかんでしょうに
日本政府みたいにね 赤字はかっこいいやと思っていいわけじゃないでしょうに
使いたい放題使いましょうとかね
人の金だろうとかね そんなもう恐ろしい罪なんですよ
石原さんも隠れてこそこそと尖閣取ってなんとか島を買ってやるぞとかね
だから でいっぱい金使ったでしょうね
誰の金ですかね あれは
勝手にやるんじゃないんですよ
まあその国民の考えがあって
国民の賛成があって使うべきものでしょうに
まあどうでもいいんですけど
しかし 国としては財産を守らなくちゃいけない
豊かにならなくてはいけない
それには異論がないでしょう
国は赤字になった方がいいや
誰が思うんで そんなこと
それだったら不放逸なんですよ
いつでもすぐすぐ行動することなんですよ
そのうち経済状況良くなるだろうと
アメリカの経済状況が良くなったら大丈夫だと
こののんきな態度 いつでもアメリカが良くなったら
アメリカが良くなった
今もうなんで円が高くない
あれはアメリカの経済状況悪いんだからとかね
アメリカですかね 全部管理しているのは
アメリカというのは世界的には驚くでしょうね
泥棒が泥棒できたらもう我々も幸せという話がどこに成り立つかよくわからないんですね
それよりも不放逸で いつでも国民のために
国のために良いことを見ていること
やってやってやっていけば
これは選挙のためにしかやらないし
どんな国でも日本だけじゃないんですよ
こんなの だから国民も最悪状態です
ギリシアの連中もね もう金使いたい放題使ったりして
イタリアもね 金で弄んで
今はもうみんな苦しんでいなきゃいかんですね
そういうことで お釈迦様がおっしゃるのは不放逸だよと
不放逸で行動すればこの世でも豊かになりますよと
で 心の問題だから 死ぬ時でも自分の心ですからね
肉体は持っていかないんだからね
不放逸の心で生まれ変わりますから
そこで当然豊かになりますと
この世で大金持ちになって
大富豪があって大成功を収めたければ
不放逸をやれと 死後もあなたは大富豪かでいたければ
はい 不放逸でやってくださいということになるんです
アッパ
マットウボアッレアディガッチャンティアディガンハティパンディトディッテーワダンマヨチャットヨチャットサンパライコアッタービサメヨディーロパンディトーティパウッチャティ
これもね お坊さんたちからも聞いて暗記しているんです
だから私は間違ってでも自分が説法するとき
自分の国では使いません
あまりにも品格のないところだけ選んで
信者さんの機嫌を取ってやろうと思うんです
この世で得るべきもの
あの世で得るべきもの
理性のある人は この両方も不放逸によって得る
もっと意味が深いんですけど
アッパマット 不放逸の人はウボアって意味
2つ意義  2つ成功しますよと
アディガッタンアディガンハティパンディト
理性ある人に智慧のある人と言うんです
で 理性じゃない 間違った
不放逸の人に智慧があると言うんです
不放逸の人は 2つの意味を獲得
有意義なことを獲得するんです
ディッテーワダンメ この世で得るべきものは全部得られます
ヨチャットサンパライト
それから死んでから得るべきものは全部もらえますと
そういうことで有意義に生きてみなさいと
有意義に生きてみるためには
不法不放逸を実践しなさいという教えになるんです
自分に有意義に生きる人は智者というんです
だから自分に有意義に生きる
その智者というのです
簡単です 有意義に生きるためには
不放逸を実践する 経典はそれで終了します
話は終了しません だから一旦休憩しましょう
では始まります はい それで今外説明しましたから飛ばします
戦友ということには 2重の意味があります
一つは自分の人格の問題で
もう一つは本当に誰かさんなんですね
このカリャーナという禅という言葉ですね
で 心が完全に清らかになるまでのプロセスが良い生き方
正しい生き方です そこで仏教ではカリャーナ禅という言葉を使ってますが
その禅というのは 心はどんどんどんどん清らかになって
完全に清らかになるまでのプロセスのことなんです
ことなんです 我々の心というのは基本的には渇愛ね
3つありますね カーワタンナー
バワタンナー イバワタンナーという
欲望と存在欲と破壊欲というね
これはお釈迦様の心理学的な要望で
現代的な言葉で言えば生きていきたいという存在欲と
まあ敵を破壊したいというね
二つの感情で生きているんだと
すべての生命はというふうに現代科学では言ってます
しかし その科学知らないのはそれ自体が無知だということなんです
だから仏教は無知も入れてます
脳科学者はちょうど二つしか使ってないんです
で これが汚れてるでしょ？生きていきたいと思ったって無理でしょ
それで我々はいつでも
あの目で耳で聞いたり見たりする瞬間で
物事は敵か味方かと判断しているんです
まず いつもそれやってますよ
たまたまですね 気づくのは
一番いい例なんですけど
たまたま初めて人に会って紹介してもらったんですけど
何のことなく 私はその人のことあまり好きじゃないと言っちゃうでしょ？言わないね
思っちゃうんですね なんでですかね
その人 初めて会ったでしょうに
初めて会ったのに 自分の脳幹がこいつは敵やともう決めているんです
だから自分ではわからない
なんでです あんたその人のことまだ知らないでしょうにと
今日紹介しただけでしょうにと
まあそう言われたって
もうなんか気に入らないと
と言っちゃいますね そういうふうに我々はわけもわからないんだけど
あるものを好きになる
あるものを嫌になる それは我々の未開発している基本
原始脳がいつでもそれだけで生きているんです
自分の味方か敵かと その上で勉強するんです
だから勉強も大して役に立たないんです
皆様も金になるものだったら喜んで勉強するでしょ
金にならないんだったら全然やりませんね
やる気が出てこない だから勉強することさえも
敵か味方かで もう主観で判断している
生きているんですね 我々は自分の生き続けることに役に立つことだけやっているんです
だから良いことをやろうとはまるっきり基本的にもないんです
生命に 皆様は生命殺すのは嫌でしょ？いい人間やと思ってるでしょ
しかし スーパーに行って
生きて生きたまんまでエビを買ったり
車エビを買ったり 貝いろんな貝種類がありますね
魚介類 それ買ったりするでしょ
なんで殺生やと思わないんですかね
アサリを味噌汁に入れたり
これ殺生でしょうに 結局自分の都合だけなんですよ
猫は殺しませんね 猫は誰か野良猫であっても人間にまで悪口を言うんですね
みんな猫を飼ってそれを
から追い出したらかわいそうでしょうとかね
まあ私たちが言って 野良猫野良犬を全部面倒見てあげなくちゃいけない
有名人になるんですね
そんなくだらんことやって
じゃあそれで優しい人かというと
生きたまんまで魚食ってるんですけど
例えばゴキブリ見ただけでえって気持ち悪くなるでしょ
ゴキブリよりもグロテスクな動物
低迷がいるんですよ エビ
エビとゴキブリを何か箱に入れて観察してみてください
誰が気持ち悪いかというと
エビの方が気持ち悪いんですよ
あまりにもグロテスクで
しかしエビはそう思わないね
ゴキブリは気持ち悪いと思っているのに
なんだこの理屈は この理屈は
脳科学が我々の原始脳が使ってるんです
ゴキブリは敵 エビは味方
味方だったら殺さないで殺して食べる
自分が食べられるんだから味方なんです
なんで害虫っていう言葉があるんですかね
ヘリコスミいいところでしょうに
害虫っていうのは 我々の農作物を食っちゃうならば害虫であって
関係ないものを殺そうとかこうならば
自然ですからありがたいですねとか
なんだ この態度は だから人間であろうか
動物であろうが みんなこの原始脳で生きているんです
あの発展している脳 大脳新皮質でではないんです
大脳新皮質は人間使ってますけど
あれは中から出てくる命令によって使っているんです
だから 脳が一番優れた人々は
それは人殺しに使っているんです
世界でたくさん科学者とたくさんの研究費は軍事に使っているんです
医学は研究のために使ってないんです
軍事開発するために使っているんです
で 我々は税金払ったりして
そういうことをやらせているんです
金は取っては軍事に使う
北朝鮮見たってようわかりやすいでしょうに
一般人が飢えているんだけど
聞いて そういう話 日本で流れますけど
よくわかりませんし その代わりにでもミサイル発射するわ
派手な祭りやるわ だからみんなに大脳皮質はありますよ
あるんだけど どうやって使うんですかね
全てこの原始脳の命令によって使う
だから動物より人間が怖いんですよ
動物の 1匹の動物が私を見て敵だと思っても
ピストルは持ってこないんですよ
夜隠れて構えてて殺してやるとはしないんです
その時 敵敵だと思って攻撃しようとするかもしれませんだけど
こちらが逃げたら終わり
話が終わり 動物はもう忘れちゃって出ていくんです
あいつは敵だから 夜 あいつの家まで行って
隠れて寝たところで殺してやるとは動物はしないでしょ
そうするためには大脳皮質は必要なんです
人間ならやります ですから
我々は本来悪人なんですよ
どんな生命も心がもう悪人というか
自分を守るかとだけに
自分を守ることだけにやっているんです
だからお釈迦様は自分を守る言葉をわざと使っているんですよ
この現代脳科学で言っていることにも使えるように
よく見事に自分を守るとは不放逸でいることやと
だから我々の原始脳が勘違いしているんだよと
原始脳に支配権をあげるなよと
監督権を これは大脳皮質にあげた方がいいんです
ですから この基本的にどんな生命でも自分を守ろうと思って
それからすべて敵と味方に分けて
その判断で生きているんです
だから禅っていうのはそのプロセスの反対なんです
だから心がゆっくりと
まず頭で考えて良いことをする
頭で考えて悪いことをしないようにする
頭で考えてやってますけど
原始脳が嫌なんです それが
あんた人を助けたらあなたの金もなくなるだろうよと
と言ってるんですよ 心の中で
あんたボランティアに行ったってもね
あなたに自分の仕事もあるでしょうにと
ボランティアに行ったら時間の無駄だろうと
心が言ってますよ 言ってるのに
頭で我々考えて行くんです
ボランティアにも 人も助けてあげたりするんです
で そういう風にじわじわじわじわと善の方に行っていて
最後にこの原始脳に勝たなくちゃいけないんです
だからそういうこの逆のプロセスですよ
善というのは その道は八正道ですね
はい その脳を改革したければ
八正道を実践するんです
善友がいれば悟れるという他力思想思考で取ってはならないんです
これは良いことに 浄土真宗の方々は読まれていないんだから
もしその経典を読んだらね
大変なことになる お釈迦様おっしゃってるでしょうにと
他力だと だって仏道は完成するんだよと言ってるんだから
善友がいれば阿弥陀様だよと言ったら
それだったらもう勘違いもいいところで
これはもう他力のことを教えているわけじゃないんです
ただただお釈迦様という方が悟り開いたんだから
我々にも手を差し伸べているだけで
悟るのは自分なんですね
だから脳のプログラムをね
原始脳の司令官である原始脳の司令官
その仕事をクビにして
大脳新皮質に司令官を与えるんです
そのためには やっぱり神経回路も別な回路システムが必要になるんです
だから瞑想しなくちゃあかんのです
で 人の心は善が好きで
善に赴くという性格が必要になります
だから私たち一人一人が善が好きですよということは
全く頑張ってでもね 作らなくちゃいけないんですよ
やっぱり良い方向へ ゆっくりでもいいんだから
良い方向へ行きましょうと
善友と言える人物がいるだけ
いるけど 自分の心は 違う方向へ働いているならば
善友論は成り立ちませんね
例えば ここら辺で本当に立派な悟りにも達した人がいるとしましょう
いるんだけど 俺が嫌いやと思ったら終わりでしょ
だから善友 善友論は成り立たないんですよ
お釈迦様おっしゃっても
善友がいれば完成しますよと言ったっても
お釈迦様がこの二重の意味を考えているんです
善に赴く性格がないと
だって 現にお釈迦様が住んでいた最序サーワッティ祇園精舎の
隣の家にいたのは豚を育てて殺して肉にして売ってる人なんですね
あいつの話嫌いやと一度も来たことはないんです
だから死んで地獄に落ちたんですよ
朝から晩まで豚を殺してはもう売っている
それでまあもう早く死にますから
殺生する人々はね で ある日
もうずっと豚の鳴き声が聞いて止まることない
朝も聞こえる 夜も聞こえる
次の日も聞こえる で アーナンダ尊者ももういてもたってもいられないね
豚の鳴き声を聞いて お釈迦様
お釈迦様の隣はね もうずっともう何日も続けて豚を殺してるんだよと
そんなたくさん肉っていうのは
王様でも来るんでしょうかと
あるいは誰かの王家の結婚式でもあるんでしょうかと
聞いたらお釈迦様 いえ
違いますと あいつはもう頭が今イカれてるんだと
今死にかけているんだから
幻覚起きているんだと
幻覚起きちゃって まあ頭の中でずっとその動物
豚たちが鳴いてる姿 もう殺さないでくれと鳴く
あれがもう全部出てきて
本人がその声を出してるんだと
だからもう明日ぐらいで死ぬでしょうと
死んでまあ行くところは決まっているという話をしたという話がありますね
はぁ ということで 立派な人がいたんだからといって
それだけで自分が救われるならばね
もう楽でしょう そんなことはあり得ません
素晴らしい先生がいるんだから
例えば英語 アメリカ人がいるんだからといって
皆様は自動的に英語できるようになりますかね
アメリカ人がいたっても
日本人が英語を学びたいという気持ちが生まれない限りは
英語好きだと英語を喋りたいんだという英語に赴く心がなければ
100人いたっても意味がないんです
アメリカ人が そういうことで
戦友論が成り立つんです
こちらも英語を学びたいと必死で
ものの見事に一人見つけたと
アメリカ人が友達になったと
だったらもう話はうまくいきます
さっさと向こういうことを覚えちゃうんです
そういうことが戦友論なんですね
性格的に個人が善を好むことが条件ですね
ですから 性格が似ているから友達になる
これから世の中の友達っていうのは性格が似ているんです
性格が善であるならば
善の仲間を見つかるんです
ブッダが意味した戦友とは
完全に解脱に達する目的がある仲間のことです
皆様にも友達がいるでしょ
あれは性格が似ているんですよ
好みが似ているんですね
だから仲良くしているんです
それで人格向上しません
だって同じですから だって噂好き
噂話をするのは好きな人が噂話好き
好きな人と仲良くなるんです
噂話は嫌いやという人は
もうなんでこの人はといって怒って敵視して出ていくんです
それで二人であることもないことも噂ばっかりしているのであって
何の人格向上もないんです
スポーツ好きな人はスポーツ好きな人と仲良くなりますけど
その場合でも ゴルフ好きな人はゴルフの仲間を作るんであって
ゴルフ好きなスポーツマンが野球のスポーツマンと友達になりません
なったとするならば 飲む時だけ
だから似ているところで友達になるんですね
だから世の中の友人論は
仏教から見れば同朋でもいいことで
大したことはないんです
そこでお釈迦様おっしゃっている完全たる友人というのは悟った人なんです
完全に心を清らかにしているんですね
その人は戦友なんです
だからといってみんな悟りません
自分の心に善味を赴く性格がないと
それから本当に善というのは解脱っていう意味なんです
この経典で 善とは解脱なんです
そこで ちっちゃな小さな善から上がって上がって上がって上がって上がって上がって
完全たる善になっちゃうんですね
解脱ということになるんです
してだってブッダのみが専有です
やっとよかったですね
私に関わらないでください
で 専有はブッダなんです
ブッダがすべてのブッダの言葉は
心清らかにする目的で教えと語られています
解脱に達する目的で語られています
ブッダが弟子たちにも戒めていますよ
あなた方の言葉が人々を涅槃に応援しないならば
無駄話だと だから説法師は誰ですかと
たくさん喋る人は説法師ではありませんと
少なく喋る人であっても
貪瞋痴をなくす道を喋っているならば
その人こそ説法師だとということで厳しいんです
といっても 私は涅槃に達する道を教えたっても
結局は私のあれ コピーじゃないでしょ
私の権利ないんです お釈迦様の言葉なんです
だから あの なんで何でしたっけ？特許
特許は釈迦様なんです
そういうことで たとえ我々今の仏教のお坊さんたちとかね
瞑想指導者とか 立派な方々はね
いますし 今日もあちゃんちゃんのエピソードも言ったでしょ
あちゃんちゃんは素晴らしいお坊様でしたし
しかし 専有はお釈迦様です
次に不放逸と専有 不放逸を実践するならば
その人がそれで専有です
だから私が専有になりますというところで
私が不放逸で生きてみようとする
それで一人一人が専有になっていくんです
最近はご利益ばかり気にするのです
それに合わせて意味をレベルダウンします
経典の 2番目は意味をレベルダウンしているんです
2番目のセクション これはもう在家ですからね
コーサラ様が だから未来の在家の方々のことも考えて
まあ金持ちになりますよということにしています
最高の幸福になりたければ
ただ不放逸をだと説く
究極な幸福になりたいんですか？あなたは
はい なります なりたい
じゃあ不放逸 頑張ってくださいと
たったそれだけ すべての仏教はアッパマーラという一言葉にまとめているんです
不放逸 お釈迦様は涅槃に入られる瞬間でも
その言葉を語られて亡くなられたんです
アッパマーデーナサンパーデータ
この不放逸はどれほど大事な言葉かというと
チャンスを逃すなよと
善を行う機会を免れないよという言葉なんです
私たちの友達 俗世間的な知り合い
仲間にも友人だというのは普通ですね
心が喜びを感じる相手がミッタなのです
この パーリ語でミッタというんですね
友達の友達はパーリ語でミッタ
ミッタさんになるとミットラになりまして
今最近新興宗教もありますね
マイトレーヨなんとか何とか言ってね
なんかカルト的な宗教もありますけど
で ミッタっていうのは
心に何か喜びを感じるんですね
誰か見たらなんか楽しくなっちゃうんですね
その人はミットラという友達というんです
だから喜びを感じる相手
感じさせる相手でもよろしいんですね
だから猫を見たらなんとなく気分がいいでしょ
ペットにするでしょ ミットラなんで友達なんです
誰かと話していると何か気持ち悪くなるんだったら
その人は友達にならないんです
だから 俗世間の友達にそんな程度なんですよ
それもわがままですよ
自分の原始脳の命令なんですよ
原始脳が喜びを感じたということは
味方だと思ったこと判断しているんです
もしかすると味方ではないかもしれません
穴を掘っているかもしれません
これは原始脳だからわからないんでしょ
だから友達関係で結構トラブルでしょ
原始脳に脳使ってないんだから
見た目で あ この人は友達やとかね
例えばブランドのネクタイをつけてくだらないガラクタを持ってピンポン鳴らったら
まあおばさんたちがね
いい若者で 本当に感じの人ですって買っちゃうでしょうね
あとで騙された騙されたと
もう電話あちらこちらかかるかけますけどね
もう遅いんですけど だから最初
原始脳でもう味方にしちゃったんです
息子みたいとかね いい青年でしたとか
愛着で 欲情で見て 品物を買ったりして
株を買ったりして 存在もしない会社の株を買うんです
で 名刺ももらってますよって言ったら
そんな住所もないしね
だからそうやってこのいろんなね
騙されたりもするでしょ
最初は戦友だと 戦友じゃなくて友達やと思ってるんですよ
それ 我々の原始脳がこの人は味方やと勝手にするんですね
調べたら味方ではないんだけど
そういうことで 俗世間の友達の関係は相当ややこしいんですよ
世間の友人はギブアンドテイクで成り立っているが
仏教は本来の友人とはそのレベルではありません
ただ単にギブアンドテイクで成り立っている関係は友人
俗世間的な友人ですけど
仏教的にはそれが友人じゃないんです
ギブアンドテイクだから終わりでしょ
話は 何かしてあげて 自分こちらもしてもらったりして
それで話が終わり だからそんな固い絆が絆がないんです
親子関係にしたって それほど固くはないんですよ
な絆は破れます 仏教でいう戦友っていうのは
この脳の改革のことなんですね
原始脳で生きているんじゃなくて
理性が司っている脳で脳に支配権を与えることなんです
原始脳の機能をストップさせるんです
プログラムで パソコンで言えばもうややこしいウイルスプログラムなんですよ
全部もうごちゃごちゃにする
これ隠れてるんですよ
ユーザーがわからないんですね
ウイルスプログラムを入れたっても
そこを見つからないように隠しておくんですよ
いわゆる合法的なファイルフォーマットを入れたりして
合法的な何かコマンドを入れたりして
それでウイルスプログラムはファイルヘディングをチェックするんだから
はい これは OK やって
OK じゃなくてウイルスなんですね
だからそういう風な もう我々の原始脳がもうとんでもないウイルスですけど
それが脳を支配しているんですね
だから そこを変えなくちゃいけないんです
そのプログラムが 自分がプログラムを変えたいという気持ちがあって
プログラムを変え変えることにアドバイスするウイルスバスターを売っているのはブッダなんですね
売ってはないんだけど
提供しているのはお釈迦様なんです
しかし これは手動でやらなくちゃいけないんです
やり方は丁寧に順番で
まずこのファイルを開けてくださいと
それの中でこのこのファイルをまた見つけてくださいと
その中でこれを見つけてくださいと
最後にこのこのものをありますよと
こういうファイルを削除してくださいと
して このこのファイルを入らないようにロックしてあげてくださいと
外からコマンドを入れられないようにと
いうふうに ちゃんと順番で
脳の開発プログラムは仏教で語られています
私は脳という言葉を使ってますけど
私は脳科学をやっている人でも勉強している人でもないんだけど
やっぱり脳科学者たちの説明
説明はある一部はね まあまあ 8 分の 1 程度ぐらいはぴったしブッダの教えに合ってるんですね
合ってないところはもう駆け足は飛ばしてます
そんなところですね だから負けてはならないというイメージ
メッセージでもあります
我々は自分の原始脳に負けているんですね
悪に負けているんですよ
汚れに負けているんですね
煩悩に負けているんです
負けるなよとブッダが言うんです
仏道は勝利者の道だと言われている
仏教の有人論を理解するならば
不放逸に挑戦です その人は俗世間的にも成功する
あの世でも成功するのです
究極の成功は解脱です
はい これで終わり だからこの負けるなよというメッセージで
仏教 その経典は一応あるみたいですね
不放逸でやってくださいと
それで善行になることはそんなに難しくないんです
これは自分の個人の問題です
で ただ 仏教は世界歩き回って人を探せと言っているわけではないんです
ブッダがどこにでもいられるように
お釈迦様が教えを全部マネジメントしてやります
どんな国に至っても 仏教にはアクセスできます
それはブッダのマネジメントなんですよ
で だいたい誰でも経典翻訳しようとかね
あれやこれやと頑張ってますけどね
まあ能力ある範囲で ですから
お釈迦様は教えがある限りブッダがいますと
ブッダが涅槃に入られたんだからといって
あなた方はリーダーがなくて困っちゃったとはないんだよと
教えがある限り私がいますよということで
常に専有がいるんです
皆様にも専有になれます
それで一番我々にトラブルを起こすのは自我でしょ
この自我があるんだから
人間関係でトラブっちゃうんですよ
自我意識が薄くなればなるほど
結局は自分の心が幅大きくなるんですね
それが専有ということですよ
全然問題ないんですね
自我が自我の錯覚がね
完全に消えたらもう専有そのものなんです
そういうことで どんどんどんどん輪が広げますよとお釈迦様がおっしゃった
自分が頑張ると家族の中の雰囲気が変わっちゃいます
自分が不法居所だったら
家族もなんとなく頑張るようになっちゃうんですね
それで家族の関係もできてるでしょう
だから国王が頑張ればもうどんどんどんどん国民まで行っちゃいますよと
それから自分を守ったことはそれであるというふうに教えているのはそのセクションです
はい ということで話を終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
お話ありがとうございました
本当に仏教のお話を聞く
勉強すること自体 今日が初めてなので
一つお話の中でわからなかったこと
知らない単語があったので教えてください
解脱という言葉が何回かスクリーンには出ていましたが
解脱というのは何でしょうか
それは輪廻転生は脱出することで
まあ普通この禅宗で悟りとか言ってるでしょ
まあそんなところですね
で 今の説明から言えば
この我々ははこの脳幹で欲と恐怖感だけできてますね
そこは逆転させることですね
全く逆にするんですね
それが解脱というんです
はい  ありがとうございます
他に質問ある方いらっしゃいます
はい では 真ん中の列の男性の方に今マイクがありますので
じゃあ順番で近い方からお願いします
すみません お願いします
今日のお話の中で 今原始脳というお話があったと思うのですが
適応とか見方を判断するとか
あと多分損得の判断というのは
普段落ち着いている時はまだ知識とか理性で止められると思うんですけど
何か自分が唐突に不利になった時
急に自分に災いが降りかかった時っていうのは
その本当の知識とか道徳を置きやって
心の奥から一挙に自分を制御してしまうようなものと感じているのですが
この原始脳っていうのはその学習能力があるとも思えないですし
自分が知識でこれは悪いことですよと思っていても
今の私の感想だと なかなか制御できるものじゃないのかなと思うのですが
この原始脳に打ち勝つ方法について何か少しアドバイスをいただきたいのですが
はい あのね 今おっしゃった通りで
よく経験していることですから
その通りなんですね しかし
この仏教ではこの観察瞑想を教えてるでしょ
観察するというね それがこのプログラムなんです
それでこの神経回路が回路が新しく現れてくるんです
そこを支配するようになってくると
原始脳があの機能をストップしてくれるんです
で それから OK ということになるんです
で なぜかというと このものすごく安らぎ感じるんですよ
生きていきたいという気持ちさえもなくなるんだから
もう死ぬのは怖いって恐怖感も消えるんですね
自由になったっていう気分が生まれてくるんです
そうすると原始脳にはもうもう仕事がないんです
だからそれは瞑想っていうのはそういうことなんで
だからそれは瞑想というプログラムなんですよ
瞑想は脳改革プログラムなんです
この現代的には脳改革プログラム
ブッダの言葉で言えば
心を改革するプログラムなんです
ブッダは脳科学者ではなかったんだからね
だからブッダは全て心理学で教えてるんです
脳科学で教えてるわけじゃないんです
それ 私が勝手に脳科学の言葉を使っただけで
それも自分が知ってもないくせにいっぱい間違いあると思います
一番ややこしいのは部品の名前なんですね
脳の あれはなんでそんな難しいかいと
わけもわからない単語を入れていて
もう 名前とやってる仕事を関係ないんです
まあおかしいんですけど
そういうことです もありますけど
だから質問の答えは このヴィパッサナー瞑想
観察瞑想と慈悲の瞑想
慈悲の瞑想の直接 この自我エゴに攻撃しているんです
だから慈悲の瞑想でも成功すると
あ 生命はみんな一緒同じやという気分感じるんですよ
生命は一体だと感じちゃったら
自分を守るという気持ちが消えちゃうでしょ
だからそれだけでも脳にはものすごい変化が起こるんです
学習能力とかなんとか言ったってもね
大したことないんで そんなのは
ただ脳細胞が機能しているだけでね
我々は学習と学習っていうのは神経回路ができることでしょ
いわゆるコミュニケーション取れることなんですね
だから大脳新皮質でいっぱい神経細胞があるし
それで新しいナーバスシステムをね
理性で管理するナーバスシステムが出来上がると言いますよ
だから当然のことだと思いますよ
まあ数学を学んだっても脳に変化が起こるでしょ
絵を学ぶ時でも脳に変化が起こるでしょ
身についた絵を描けるようになったっていうことが
この筋肉やらそのところで頭に浮かぶイメージをどうやって手で表現するのかというシステムができているということでしょうに
だから瞑想する時も当然脳は変わるでしょうと思いますね
まだ調べたことはそれほどないんですが
だから慈悲の瞑想ってヴィパッサナー瞑想ですよ
だからそこら辺ちょっと調べてみてください
ありがとうございました
では 次の方 前のほうの方
お願いします  通常 我々凡夫は自我という錯覚を持っていて
原始脳を使って 新皮質ももちろん持ってはいる人間なんだけれども
それを突き動かしているのは原始脳であると
しかしながら ブッダの開発された解脱
解脱できるという方法があり
それを解脱の可能性といいますか
もともと人間は解脱すること可能性があって
その可能性は瞑想によって実践されると
そのように考えてよろしいのでしょうか
うん 変わらないと思います
はい  ありがとうございます
脳科学者の方々は このこうやって機能するするんだよと説明するだけで
これ変えるということは
ちょっとその技術は持ってないんですね
最近読んだ本でも そういう方法があればなんてありがたいかということだけはあるんですね
で 私が言いたいのはありますよと
簡単に変える方は だからおっしゃる通りに
まあ一応変える可能性がありまして
そのプログラムで変えられればよろしいということです
はい  えっと もう少し時間ございますけど
質問がありましたら では
川本さん  すいません 内容じゃないんですが
ご清聴感謝します 清聴はその感じで
なに？ 今回はよろしいですか
ご清聴の  あ これは私の間違いです
チェックしなかったんです
新しい新しいパソコンで作ったんだから
この記録してないんです
全部一つ一つ調べなくちゃいけなくなっちゃって
はい はい  えーと 欲の喜びっていうのはですね
あの六門を使って感じると思うんですが
その瞑想の喜びとか楽っていうのは
どこでどのように感じるんでしょうか
それで瞑想すれば感じますけど
笑 蜂蜜の味はどこで感じますか？といえば
蜂蜜をなめることでしょうね
で 瞑想して我々はもうまあたまたまにもね
まあ瞑想をむちゃくちゃやっていると
もうこの原始脳がもうどうしようもなくなる時があるんですよ
どうしようもなくなった瞬間で喜びを感じちゃうんですね
欲から離れる喜び これの方が楽だというふうに
そうやってちらちらと感じちゃうと
脳が学ぶんですよ 脳脂質はね
騙されていたんだと 原始脳に
それでどんどん向こうの方が力強くなっていくんです
それは瞑想してみるしかないんですね
欲の喜びあるということは錯覚です
欲は苦しみだと あれはクタクタ疲れてるでしょうにと仏教では言うんだけど
それが何が楽しいなのかと
あれは楽しみというよりも
このこの原始脳が 生き続ける生存欲を応援して １票もらったというふうな感じなんですね
原始脳がいつでもものすごく恐怖感で怯えているんです
死ぬことは確かです いつでもそのデータが入っているんです
細胞死んでるんだからね
ずっとそのデータが入ってるんです
だから瞬間でも原始脳が落ち着かないんです
そこで我々は意図的に何か命を応援することをやると
微妙にホッとする あ  １票もらったとかね
それですよ 喜びというのは
それとは質が違いますよと
瞑想で感じる喜びは本物です
錯覚じゃないんです  やってみればわかるだけで
この一般的にこれっていう風には説明できません
離れる喜びとは言葉はあるんだけど
それは何かということは
まあやってみなきゃわからないんですね
離れる喜びと言ってますからね
ヴィヴェーカ スカン ピーティ
スカン アナワッジョ スカン
ネッカンマ スカンとかね
スカという言葉は結構使ってます
欲の喜びはカーマスカンと言ってますけどね
それは疲れますよと はい
ありがとうございます
すいません 僕の あの その原始脳ですよね
原始脳ってプログラムなんですけれども
この間ちょっとNHKを見てましたら
人間が狩猟をしている時には争いがほとんどないと
農耕社会に移ってから
その畑を守るとか そういうことを財産を守るというような状態で
争いとか武器とかが発達してきたと
で その原始脳というものは
この悟りっていうのはもうすごい高度な話で
人間がその現実に生存するためには
その原始脳というプログラムがないと生存できないと思う
であれば その原始脳のその正体というのはですね
その生命がもう始まった
そのバクテリアの時代から
もともと原始脳というプログラムがあったのか
人間の農耕社会とか そういうある程度
その歴史が新しい状態になった時に
そういう原始脳というものが作り上げられたのか
原始脳のプログラミングっていうのはいつ頃組み立てられたものなのか
その辺どう  はい この辺で
この脳科学は仏教に使ってはいけないというメッセージもあります
で あの微生物には脳がないでしょう
で 脳っていうのは集合体が出来上がって出来上がって
集合体が細胞の数がね
あまりにもたくさんになってくると
細胞が組織化になっていくでしょうね
だから この複数の組織
細胞 組織を管理するためにもう一つ細胞組織が現れたんですね
それに脳と言ってるんですよ
しかし 細胞 1個も生きてます
微生物も生きてます 生きてる生命はみんな生存欲があるんだから生きてるんです
だから おっしゃる通りに生存欲がなければ生き続けないということもあります
だからこの それで良かったか悪かったかってないでしょう
結局よく見ると悪かっただけなんでしょうしね
生き続けたいと思ってますけど
みんな失敗しているでしょ
いろんなカラクリいますよ
ただ 我々には 1個細胞ではあまりにもやばいんです
1個の細胞 寿命って短いでしょ
微生物っていうのは瞬時に死んじゃうでしょ
これやばいんだだからもう一つにつなげているんですね
それでも死んじゃうんだから
今我々は難聴の細胞をつなげてつなげてごまかしやっているんです
が 細胞は一個一個自分の寿命で死んでるんですね
だから組織だけ壊れないということになっているんですね
だからそれで誰が生きてるんですかと
組織といったって細胞が死んでるんだからね
体の細胞 全部 3ヶ月続かないで全部死んじゃっちゃうでしょう
それでも俺が生きてるんだよと言ってますけど
本当かいと だからただ組織が機能しているだけでね
だからこの生きるというこの観念ですよ
それもそれに引っかかる必要ないとブッダが解くんですね
だから今おっしゃった通りに生存欲がなければ大変だとか言ったっても
何が大変かと ということで
すごい深い話になりますよね
膨大な話になります だから短く答えることはできませんだけど
脳中心に考えるのは私たち現代人なんですね
しかし 脳細胞とニューロン細胞が現れる以前
かなり前からの生命はいたんです
地球上の生命には 一応細胞みたいな何か物質的なからくりが必要で
物質的なからくりなくても生命を生むんだよと仏教は言うんですね
だから必ずしも脳がなければということじゃないんです
細胞も一個一個自分で判断します
大した判断ではないんだけど
判断しています 体の細胞は一人一人自分の仕事をちゃんと真面目にやって
うまくいかないとうまくいかないと信号を出したりして
そこでいろんな組織が機能してなんとかやってくれますね
膝の関節の細胞には仕事できなくなっちゃうと
もうなんかもうなんて言いますか
叫ぶんですね その叫ぶっていうことは
もう化学物質になっちゃって
それからそこは脳が感じて
あらゆる組織に命令するんですね
医者のところに行けとかね
あるいは座れとかね あれこれやと
そういう風に助け合って
なんとか生き続けようとしているだけで
でも負けます 全部壊れます
だから この執着捨てるっていうことは
生命にはなかなか理解できないことなんです
あなた 一番大事なことを捨てるって言ってるではないかと
そのおかげで生きてる
生きてるんではないかという気持ちが出てくるんです
だからお釈迦様は仏教は人に語るもんじゃないやと思ったんだからね
仏教が究極の幸福を見つかっているのに
これ言っちゃうとまたまずいと
もうだからもうお釈迦様は結構苦労しましたよ
この説法するために人間にどうやって発表すればいいかっていうことはね
相当な力使ったんだから
ソワッカとバゴタだ もうブッダの教えは見事に説かれているんだっていうことは
もう大変な言葉なんです
もう人間は聞き 聞きたくないんです
生存欲を応援するならば聞くんです
だから NHK でああいうふうなことを言われたってもね
農耕民族になってきて戦争が現れましたと
私から見れば 狩猟民族でいた時はずっと殺していたんだからね
だから殺したい殺したいという衝動には行く場がなく
吐き場がなくなっちゃって
じゃあ人を殺しましょうと
だから大した変化がないんで
それでも 我々は他誰か殺す者がいれば人殺しに行かないんです
だいたい人殺した人を見ると
テレビでもまたいろいろインタビューするでしょ
周り本当にいい人でしたとかね
家族を大事にした人でしたとか
あれはこれ言うでしょうに
だから殺す場がなかったんですね
それで誰か殺しちゃったんです
結局は細胞単位で見ても
生存欲と敵を殺したいという衝動
2つがあるんです 生きるっていうことは
ただのもう何のこともないということはわからないんだから
ブッダが無知ということをまず入れるんですね
無知があるんだから生存欲が生まれて
無知があるんだから破壊欲も生まれてくるんだと
いうことで まあこの渇愛 3つの場合はもうまとめる場合 2つですね
カーマタンナ ババタンナっていうのは生存欲で
ヴィババタンナーはもう破壊欲で
そちら無明は入れてないんです
別なところで教えるとか
無明を入れたりする そういうことで
まあ結構大変複雑で解かれてます
これは私たちは本来聞きたくないんで
仏教は 私は仏教好きよ
好きよと言ったってもね
これはちょっとおかしい
あまり好きじゃないと言ったら
これはもう素直な気持ちだと思います
生存欲でできてるんだからね
細胞全部 だから質問がいつごろかっていうことはね
それは成り立たない質問
答えは成り立たないんですね
なぜならば 突然現れません
何も 突然現れるってことはあり得ない
何か原因があって現れるんです
ということで 最初の細胞がということに考えたっても
それが現れるためには何か原因があったんです
もし物質だけ揃ったら
最初の生命体 細胞が生まれたと言ったならば
今も新たな細胞種類が生まれているはずなんです
それはウイルス調べると出てきますよ
ウイルスには新たなウイルスが出てきます
あのインフルエンザじゃなくて
鳥インフルエンザウイルスみたいなね
しかし 原因がありますね
あるウイルスが変わった
遺伝子変わっただけ ですから
これはどこまで遡ってもまたあるということになるんだから
そこは放っておいてくださいと
見いだせないということにしてくださいと
というのがブッダの言葉なんです
いくら遡ってみてもまだあるんだと
だから因果法則で見た方がわかりますよと
例えばあのパイという円のあれ
計算するとき使う数字があるでしょ
で パイは割って小数点にすれば
これは無限に行くでしょうに
だから単純計算で考えれば
これは終わらないんだとわかるでしょう
終わりがありませんと
それで十分ですよ ただ数えてみたっても同じことさ
1 2 3 4 どこまで？終わりがないでしょ
じゃあ逆にマイナスしてみれば終わりがないんです
だからそこは方式フォーミュラ
この方式だけ聞かしてくださいということなんです
だから因果法則なんですね
それで見たら このいつからですか？っていう質問はまあやめてよということになるんです
えーと パイはパイの値はね
小数点にすれば最後の数字は何なのかと
ちょっとやめてちょうだいよ
というような話です はい
ありがとうございました
では 次の方でお話してくれます
どうもありがとうございます
えーと うちの母親が七十過ぎてて
もう年寄りでいつ死んじゃうかわからない年齢なんですけど
元気なんですけど なんとか親孝行したいなと思ってまして
全然今まで親孝行らしい親孝行してなかったので
何か急にその今まで何もその親子らしい会話もしてなかったので
急に親孝行するのもちょっとどうしていいかわかんなくて
今回のテーマだと母親のその役に立つような何か善意という母親の善意というか
母親に何かお返しできるような方法というか
考えると やっぱり仏教とか興味持ってほしいなと思って
スマナサーラ長老の本とかを一冊プレゼントしたんですけど
すごい喜んでくれたんですけど
そんな感じでなんか仏教の本とかプレゼントするとか
そういうので親孝行になるのかなと思いまして
お母様が喜んで読むならば
それは見事な親孝行なんですよ
それは問題ないんです
もしお母様が慈悲の瞑想でもやってみることになったらね
最高の親孝行になるんですね
だからお母様の心が善友に変わるんだからね
それに勝る宝物はないんですよ
だから本当の親孝行っていうのは
親に禅の道を紹介することであると
お金あげたっても あなたの借りがもっと多いやと
あの仏教でいい例えがあるんですよ
ある男が自分の両親を両肩に乗せてもらって
寝るのも食べるのも 大便
小便するのも 体洗うのも全部背中肩の上でやってあげても
100年やったっても
親の借りは借りやと消えませんよと
それぐらい子供に親が与えているんだよと
だからそうやって物質的には親孝行っていうのは仕切れないものであると
では どうすればと 親に善を教えなさいと
親を善の道に導きなさいよと
それで親孝行やと完了やということですから
あんたやってることはそのままいいとは思います
問題ないと思います 親孝行していると思います
で もうちょっと喜んでやってください
あんたちょっと一つ欠けていることは
俗世間的なことですけどね
よく褒めてあげてくださいよ
親を 大げさなことではもうお母さんに感謝してください
まあハガキを送ってあげたりとかね
ちょっとどこかでいい絵はがきでも見つけたら
なんのことなお母さんありがとうという一言で送ったりとかね
そういう風にこのありがとうっていう言葉をね
よくよく言ってあげてください
それでかなり効き目が違います
全然言ってないですね
うん それが欠けていると思います
それが言ってください
口で言うの恥ずかしいんだったら
ハガキから始めてください
何かどこかでいい写真でも撮ったら
この写真撮った時お母さんを思い出しましたと
どう？写真見て なんでこれ？こいつは私をこれで思い出すのかとか
それどうでもいいんです
理屈は 理屈ないところすごくかっこいいんですよ
例えばスカイツリーでも見に行ったところで
自分が写真撮ったら お母さん
これ写真撮ったところでお母さんのことを思い出しましたと
一行書いて送る それでものすごく心が喜ぶと思います
それからあなた仏教の本をあげたら
何の躊躇もなく読むんです
うちの息子はできた息子やと
あいつは悪く間違ったことをしないやという信仰に入っているんです
それよりそれも一応やってあげてください
はい  ありがとうございました
では そろそろ時間ですので終了したいと思います
最後に皆さんで回向の文を修業したいと思います
唱和してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビートリヨウィラージャントーサンバローゴウィナッサトーマテーバワットアンタラーヨスケディーガーユコーバワーバワトゥサッバマンガランラッカントゥサ
ッバデーヴァタサッバブッダヌバーヴェーナサッバダンマヌバーヴェーナサッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダーソッティーバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリッサニッチャンワッダパチャイノーチャッ
taruダンマワッダンキヤーイワッノーシュカンバランアーイラーローギヤサンパッティサッガサンパッティミーウェッチャアトゥーニンバーナサンパッティティミナケーサミンジェトゥ
サッーサッーサッー  では
長い時間どうもありがとうございます